[Music]
hello and welcome to safety Ridge on
Sunday live from Birmingham where the
Conservative Party conference is about
to get underway and I think it's fair to
say it's been a bit of a rocky start the
Prime Minister's brexit plan has been
described as deranged by the former
foreign secretary backbenchers have been
lining up to helpfully offer their
alternative visions for the party and
there was an embarrassing and
potentially very serious data breach
with the conference at yesterday while
tourism a has hit back warning that
splits could damage the national
interest so lots to discuss with our
guests today in a moment we'll be
speaking to the man responsible for this
conference and it's at the Conservative
Party Chairman Brandon Lewis later on in
the show we'll be joined by the former
brexit secretary David Davis and we'll
also be speaking to the leader of the
Scottish Conservatives Ruth Davidson
Plus we'll be looking through the Sunday
papers with the former Home Secretary
Jackie Smith and the broadcaster in down
first party conferences are supposed to
be about uniting the party engaging the
members announcing policies
needless to say accidentally exposing
the mobile phone numbers of everyone
tending isn't it quite part of the plan
so let's talk now to the man in charge a
conference for the Conservatives the
party chairmen Brandon Lewis I've got to
ask you first about what happens with
the Conservative Party app I mean this
is not the start to conference that you
wanted how serious is are you taking
this oh well any breach of data is a
serious matter that's why we are taking
it seriously though we were
investigating we've already contacted
the Information Commissioner we'll be
putting in a fuller reports there and
we've spoken to the company that
supplied who themselves have put out a
statement apologizing for the error that
they made this will affect people where
somebody's guests or already news
somebody's email address and was able to
therefore log in as them so it'll be a
limited number of our delegates here but
we are contacting the delegates that
comes to our onto them exactly what has
happened and what they can do about that
so but any bridge is a serious bridging
that's why we are fully investigating it
and are taking it very seriously can you
say it's a limited number of delegates
but these are some potentially very
important people
I mean the foreign secretary for example
is the former foreign secretary one of
them and I mean who's responsible for it
and how many people are we actually talk
to you about well I'm not I can't get
into the details at the moment in terms
of the numbers but we're doing that
investigation at the moment working with
the company who supplied the app who
supply companies like Barclays and
Nissan and eBay for Commerce's and
things around the world but it is
serious any breach of data services why
we are taking it so within within
finding out about this issue yes during
half an hour we had fixed this problem
the company had shut that security issue
down so yeah he's now functioning fully
properly and securely there are a number
of delegates where if somebody logged in
who already knew their email address
they would have been able to see the
photograph the email address that they'd
use to log in and if it was there a
mobile phone number and that's happened
that was affected a few people as you've
rightly outlined and we are working with
all of the delegates and comments to let
them know exactly what has happened you
see it it it's easy to be talked about
this is like you know an embarrassment
but actually it could be serious
couldn't it you and I both know how
toxic a political discourse can be at
the minute you know people in the public
how I get raped threats and death
threats on Twitter I mean can you look
me in the eye and say that those threats
and not now can be sent to somebody's
mobile phone number because someone's
happen to guess their email address well
as I say we are working with all we're
working all the delegates of Congress we
do a full investigation to see what
exactly and who exactly was able to be
accessed in this way let's say so you
had to already have their email address
they unfortunately be able to go in like
this but for some for some people yes
you can and actually one of the things
we have got to be careful that in our
society and I've talked about this a lot
over the last few months is that ability
to have proper robust debate but with
respect without that kind of hard abuse
that we are seeing I would argue for
many on the hard left
particularly on social and digital media
now security issues in the dirty buy as
I say this I'm not for a moment
any breach is anything other than
seriousness why we are taking seriously
it's why we deal with it being half now
being aware of it yesterday that's why
the company has put its statement out
and we will be putting a full report a
with an investigation into the
in Information Commissioner's Office did
you consider resigning at the moment I
focus on making sure that conference
goes well that the attendees have a
really good conference but yesterday we
got that app sorted as quick as we
possibly can and get to the bottom of
exactly how that happened and why I
happened okay let's move on to things
I'm sure you'll perhaps be more
comfortable talking about which is the
message that you're going into this
Conservative Party conference with
because what we've seen in the last week
or so is a whole range of conservative
MPs effectively coming forward and
saying you're not offering a
distinctively our vision talk compared
to labor I mean the list I hear some
gmail is trust Jacob Riis more Robert
Halfin pretty Battelle Boris Johnson all
spoken out so can you tell me what is
the distinctive message that these MPs
can go out and sell on the doorstep well
there's a couple of things I would say
to that first of all I think one of the
strengths are the conservative parties
that we are and do have this great wide
team of therapy with buzzing with ideas
and you'll see a lot of that this week
of comments as the government itself
will also be outlining our ideas and our
plans to the next period of time in
government to take our country forward
in a really positive way and actually
that's in big contract what is the
distinctive what's the saying I think
two things that I think that is in big
contrast what we saw last week was old
hat ideas that actually would have fit
pensioners really damage pensioners in
terms of the equity proposals we would
the changes in corporation tax would
affect jobs but we as a party will be
outlined in this week is about how we
want to make sure we are giving
opportunity to people but good education
the chance to benefit from more jobs in
our economy to have job security and the
investments we're making in both
infrastructure and in our public
services you see I asked for the
distinctive master budget and the things
that you listed there I think that most
parties could probably say now you know
we want to give it good and education
and want to give opportunities and what
is distinctive offering I think there's
a very big difference between us and the
Labour Party distinction what is
distinctive is these are things we are
doing and we are outlined in very firm
plans about how to take them further
into the future not things that can't be
forwarded not things that can't be
delivered things we are doing things we
can do in the future to make things what
is that distinctive vision what it is
about making sure we are providing the
things that matter to me
every day about make sure they do get a
good education we're building more homes
for people to be able to act in a home
of their own for them and their family
to make sure we are investing in our NHS
in the long term to make sure it
continues to be a world leading health
service that is how we invest in our
public services and the biggest
investment program in our infrastructure
and our roads and all that we've seen in
a generation making sure we getting our
country ready and fit for the future I
just want to have a look at what Robert
Hoffman said in particular he wrote he's
an MP for Harlow the problems with the
Conservatives is at the corbin
description of what's going on resonates
with millions of people failing railways
increased homelessness families
struggling despite working every day our
infrastructure under strain high streets
closing crime on the rise and all the
things these things are true aren't they
can you really say that people's lives
are better now compared to when you
first came into power eight years ago
yes there's maybe 2 million more
children getting good an outstanding
education in 2010 there's about a
thousand new jobs a day being created
since 2010 for housing we have actually
increased labor left us with a lowest
level of house building since 1923 about
75,000 homes a year we're back up to
220,000 and rising so we are delivering
and getting onto that ship Everage we
want to build a 300,000 homes a year
we're investing more in our NHS than
ever before so yes we are doing those
things we've also got to make sure we
take the opportunity of a week like this
so we just talking about that explaining
why that is good and why it's delivering
things for people as opposed to Labor's
promises that just can't deliver and
often as we've seen in the last year
they then renege on later anyway during
the policy you're announcing a policy
stay on you around housing and strategy
to what just explained well what we've
recognized these people have said for
some time that they get frustrated
particularly in our cities in someone
like London but people from overseas
will come in and buy properties when
actually they want to see British people
hire new people in the UK having first
option on those properties so what we're
doing we've already changed there also
is the properties have to be advertised
here in the UK but for people overseas
people are not UK taxpayers will pay an
extra standard we're going to consult on
the figure but around 1% we're going to
consult to see if that's the right
figure and the money the income from
that that comes to come we'll go into
the rough sleeping help you some of the
most vulnerable people
in the country you speak a bit earlier
about how you're hoping that you can be
able to talk about the sort of domestic
vision if you like does it worry you
sometimes that it feels that all the
kind of band width is taken up by brexit
in the minute I mean that's fine for
obvious it's very important six months
towards leaving the EU but for you
you're in charge gaming bodes it's not
really the most exciting thing to be
selling on the doors deficit well brick
cities as you say it's a huge issue for
our country one of the biggest projects
the government has undertaken of any
type since it's probably the second
world war and it is hugely important
that we get this right that we get the
deal with the European Union that
delivers for the country and respects
the referendum so there is a big issue
and the media and people around the
country are interested in that but what
we saw this year in the local elections
where we had a really good set of
results and what you'll see it comes
this week is us talking about what
happens after bricks it as well that
domestic agenda as I say delivering for
people in their lives every single day
now and you mentioned the local election
so we stated well obviously the last
general election was a bit of a
disappointment for you to say the least
Labour say they are on an election
footing they're ready to go are you
ready for an election well I'm working
on the local elections for 2019 next
general election is 2022 it might come
you are you ready to go if there was an
election earlier I'm not working
hypotheticals the election we are
working on the next election is the
local elections next year the general
election is 2022 and no we didn't get
the result we wanted last year but we
did show in the local elections this
year when Labour said they were going to
win pretty much every council seat I
think certainly London if not the
country actually labor didn't do that
we had the success in the local
elections this year making gains all
over the country taking back control of
a council in from Labour in London in
Barnet and actually they didn't win any
of those councils so I think we showed
in those elections that we can but do
that job we can win those local actions
but that was just stage one there is a
big piece of work for us to do and we've
got big local elections next year we'll
Tereza mainly the conservators into the
next general election I hope she will
and I think she will yes because this is
the Prime Minister's bringing our
country together I getting that deal
with the European Union I'm confident we
will get a good deal with the United
Kingdom in the EU that delivers on the
referendum delivers for our economy in
the future and with that strong domestic
agenda delivering for people right
across our country I think that's a
powerful message
go into the next general election with
and now while we've got to you I want to
ask you about Skye's campaign for an
independent commission to see leaders
debates the general elections is that
something you'd welcome well I'm not yet
seeing too many times where Krang goes
and commissions has given us the perfect
answer to everything I think we've got
to look at where we are at the general
election look at what is happening in
the country and make a decision at that
point at the same time though you know
the whole point of having an independent
commission is to take it out of the
hands of politicians and also the
broadcasters so that it's you know an
independent body working out the details
that's got to be a good thing that's not
what I think actually want to see more
democracy well I sure do and that's what
the general election itself is about
people going out and voting based on the
information they get from their local
candidates well they get through the
national media the social and digital
media I think will be increasing in the
next election possibly to the point
where overtakes many other things if
we're looking three or four years down
the line so I think we do need to look
at it's much near the time and take a
decision based on what is happening in
media across the country so you're not
ruling out that you think it could be a
good idea I'm not ruling out I'm not
running it in E but I think we need to
look at where we are completely all the
time
okay Brandon Lewis thanks very much well
it's time to take a look through these
Sunday newspapers with I guess the
former Labour Home Secretary Jackie
Smith and the broadcaster in dental
thanks very much for being with us and
it feels like we should start with the
interviews that the Prime Minister and
the former foreign secretary Boris
Johnson have given to the Sunday Times I
mean it struck me number 10 can't be
very happy that their big interview with
the Prime Minister has suddenly been
turned into you know a jewel if you like
between her and Boris Johnson what well
I can't imagine that number two knew
that the Sunday Times are doing an
interview with Boris Johnson and I can
almost guarantee you that next year's
Party conference that we do the
interview with The Mail on Sunday rather
than the Sunday Times and when you
contrast the two interviews and I'm not
a fan of Boris Johnson but you have to
save his interview there are actually a
few policies that are quite innovative
whereas in the prime ministers you've
got this idea for a festival after back
sir well great
you've got this idea of taxing
foreigners a bit more when they buy
houses in this country and well that's
kind of it and you think well is that
really the big conference announcement a
three percent surcharge on house prices
for foreigners right you know the front
of probably the best red newspaper here
at the conference with Boris and Teresa
may as you say looking as if they're in
a jewel cannot be helpful for her
although she sort of comes out fighting
in the interview yeah she does doesn't
she I mean but I mean I guess the issue
again is that Boris with his use of
language and calling checkers deranged I
mean it immediately steals the headlines
and then means it's what everyone he's
got to be really careful here because if
you notice as an interview David Davis
and the Sunday Telegraph
yeah any other sort of language it's
actually and I mean he resigned on
principle Boris will say that he
resigned on principle but we all know he
only resign because David Davis resigned
rather than on the principle of checkers
so I think to do that article on Friday
was one thing and I think there were
some interesting things in that
but of course it was done to overshadow
the launch of the conference he's doing
a fringe meeting which will no doubt be
the biggest event of the conference and
he's got to play his hand very carefully
because he's not popular among
conservative MPs and if he wants to take
over the leadership he's got to get
their support before he gets the support
of politic this is my first visit to
concerns den but what I suspect is like
any political conference it's full of
people who were the ones that are out on
the streets slogging around local
councillors trying to get elected trying
to keep their party in government and I
agree with Ian I don't think people like
that are that impressed with a load of
grandstanding in advance of their
conference you know and as you say
porous is getting a reputation for the
sort of controversial language that
overshadows the see
business actually for the rest of the
country of the goatier ting a brexit
deal and presumably some of the other
things that perhaps they'll want to talk
about this week let's talk about that
David Davis interview as well because
obviously I should say David Davis
resigned to you know over the checkers
deal - he's pretty critical here at
number Ten's
approach saying that they are not being
strong enough in these negotiations that
we need to be more robust what did you
make it back to do well I think he's
absolutely right I think when the
history books are written at this period
Ollie Robbins Teresa Mays chief adviser
I think he's going to get a lot of
criticism clearly David Davis and he
didn't get on
he thought that Ollie Roberts was
adopting the wrong tactics but in also I
mean David Davis has got to take some
responsibility he was the brexit
secretary all of this time and maybe he
should have been a little bit more what
a bit tougher on on number ten and he
was the one seeing Michelle Barney yeah
he was the one during the face-to-face
negotiations with Michelle ba-ba so I
mean I agree with a lot of what he said
but I know you're gonna be talking to
him later but I mean that's actually a
more interesting interview in many ways
because you sort of get a little bit of
perspective of what's going on that is
so much like a leadership pictures the
voice one does but I mean you know it is
a bit rich you can have a go Ollie Robin
so you can have a go at Teresa may the
Brixton negotiations are roshambo but at
least those two are still there trying
to make something of it whereas the
people who have been responsible for us
Johnson David Davis freed from the
shackles have actually happened to do
any work are now sort of criticizing the
things that they were he was the foreign
secretary the goodness sake Ian you're
not telling me that he wasn't having us
saying what the government
that tells you what you need to know do
you think there is an argument that they
have more of an influence over brexit
from the backbenchers because they can
lay out this new different vision from
checkers well I think what's going on
here now is that you are getting
different visions you have the Institute
of Economic Affairs publishing that
paper on Monday you've had the European
research group published various
proposals and so she had Boris Johnson's
4,000 articles so a lot of people
accusing that the levers of not having
anything to say no firm proposals but
you're not really accusing you may
disagree with them but they are actually
coming out with proposals now maybe a
bit late in the day that they are there
but what's cleared from this and it
would be interesting to see how much it
plays out and the conference's you know
there are 57 varieties of different
views on what should happen to breakfast
it and of course increasingly we see
Tory remain as as well going as far as
arguing for a people's vote hi Alan I
think I think it's pretty looks pretty
unlikely that Parliament's are going to
be able to come to a view and therefore
there is only one way to sort this out
that's tamartian people house the
Ottoman people so generally yeah and I
don't think that's you know regardless
of what was decided last week at Labor
conference I don't think that's likely
to happen
I think more likely to happen with
people come together and there is a real
stalemate in Parliament is to say to the
British people do you actually yes sir
there's no way that Theresa May will do
that if Parliament is gridlocked as you
say they'll either come up with some
other proposal or there will be a
general election there will never be
another not while she's in power and the
general election will be interesting of
course because what position will both
parties take as they go into it and I
have to say from like my conference last
week it wasn't only clear what that
position would be if there was an
election I think we have a sharp
negative all the kind of policies could
be in order it feels like we should talk
about the other story that everyone is
chanting about our conference already
and that is that extraordinary security
breach with the conference app but this
is on the front page of The Sunday
Telegraph force morning as well and it's
pretty shocking well I got a text from a
friend yesterday afternoon saying even
if your number until this happens a bit
of a cluster whatever I said what you're
talking about he's saying this
conference up and I thought I didn't
know the one side download it it's
actually quite impressive when you look
at the audit the fact that people being
able to access these phone numbers
something that is just appalling I mean
I did my immediate thought was well is
there somebody in the company that built
it that sabotage don't buy I don't think
that was the case I think it's just
ranking competency well how do you even
build these things if you can't do the
security these are people that's
supposed to be finding a technological
way to solve the problem of the border
in northern I
and they can't keep pieces they cannot
keep people's information on an app what
you do is in the service I think it well
knows you hire a specialist company to
build the app what you also know me in
is you take responsibility as a
political party for the people that you
conservative are the prime minister to
design a responsibility for big
organizations have spent a lot of time
worrying about GDP are in the last few
months and the types of fines but unlike
you to be there when people who've been
polisher and League of three million
HMRC that's bad and that was bad right
this is very bad responsibility
I'm not calling for anybody to resign
apart from the whole government for
being incompetent on a whole range of
payments rather absolutely this up on
that note let's perhaps you get a bit
more agreement over this is about the
bodyguard the story you've selected
favorite food forget potatoes and
puddles rally was the bodyguard what is
it I actually had to watch The Bodyguard
and now I know this is terrible isn't it
I really need to enjoy night without the
body part but it's ok because you can
read this biography on Ferrari by Anna
beer in which he said he was effectively
the body count in his relationship with
a little Lizabeth the first was as she
says there it wasn't a lot of sized
political relationship not a political
sexual relationship not much all the
differences and Elizabeth was on top
racing there you go you obsessed by this
just because you didn't bump your new
home secretary well I love the first
couple of episodes but I thought it
slightly went downhill after that
apparently they had a different director
a spoilers they have they had a
different director for the last three
episodes I think and that did affect her
there wasn't quite as Brooklyn wasn't
like the last of the nos absurd with
really good people in it don't say too
much yeah no no yeah me and other
viewers I'm sure as well and well thanks
for to talk about a whole range of
stories from you know bunking to
breakfast well Ruth Davidson has been
credited with leading the resurgence of
the Conservative Party in Scotland and
without Scottish MPs the Tories would
actually have lost the last election so
little wonder perhaps that she's been
tipped as a future prime minister
something she ruled out in the last week
so let's find out why
welcome thanks very much for being with
us thank you as we start we was talking
to the party chairman Brandon Lewis and
before earlier on in the program about
this security breach it could be quite
serious couldn't it I mean in a time
when after school discourse is so toxic
I mean have you received any calls from
any pranksters well no but then I didn't
put my mobile number in the app but to
be honest yeah I think there was an
issue there it's been resolved it got
resolved very quickly and but people
don't have to have your mobile number to
be toxic to you you can see that through
social media everyday so yes of course
the party is going through all of the
appropriate inspections and remedies
that are there and it is embarrassing
there's no getting away from that but it
was identified early it was fixed
quickly and then we move on well let's
move on and we just break set of course
is the big issue going into the
contracting party conference you
campaigned very strongly for remain in
that referendum now the only credible
proposal on the table we're told is the
checkers arrangement and something that
Boris Johnson's described just arranged
and something that the EU have said will
not work if it was a choice between
No Deal and a second referendum would
you support a second referendum well
first of all I think I need to address
the premise of your question because yes
there are areas of impasse between the
EU and the United Kingdom government
position but we know that that we're
working on that and after Saltzburg and
a blow-up which slightly cleared the air
actually we know that officials are
working very closely together from the
UK and the Irish side with proposals in
the Irish backstop and also between the
UK and the EU sites to look at the
impact of the economic agreement so I
think there's still the basis there for
a deal to be done and and I would always
prefer there to be a deal than no deal
but when it comes to rerunning
referendums I would be an enormous
hypocrite if I say it just because there
was one that I had lost as a remainder
and we should immediately read on it
when I spent four years in Scotland
saying Nicola Sturgeon shouldn't get
another one our independence because
that's one that I want so I'm not
actually an agreement that we need to
have another referendum would you prefer
to see no deal then
the second referendum I think that's a
false choice that you're giving us
because there is a deal it's on the
table that everyone is working towards
and we saw really a pulse towards it
because it was in May is said that she
was chair to see no deal than a bad deal
so she's spoken of the possibility of no
deal the government's been releasing you
know it's preparations for no deal it's
not something that I'm just putting up
my back pocket it's something that we
are criticized the government for for as
people where earlier this year for not
doing enough preparations with the
possibility of your deal and then
criticize them for doing preparations
for an ordeal and as you see the Prime
Minister's choice is between a deal or
no deal not between some form of deal or
you know another referendum that's not
what's on the table what's on the table
is a credible set of proposals were a
long way towards getting agreement there
are two areas of in us and I think it
beholds the government and the EU to try
and make sure we deliver for the people
of all of our respective countries and
that means trying to resolve these areas
of impasse we've got a very tight time
schedule before the next EU summit in
October and but I think there's a dealer
to be done and I support the Prime
Minister in getting it and I think part
of what the party should be doing is
giving her the space to get in and get
the job done and I think perhaps some of
the noises off perhaps need to count
over calling the deal deranged that's
probably not something that you know I
mean I don't particularly use language
like that when I'm discussing area so
you know geopolitics and I don't think
it's Weishaupt to do but what I think is
strange about some of the attacks that
are in the newspaper is today is this is
someone who was praising what the Prime
Minister brought through in terms of
moving on to the next stage last
December someone who was in you know one
of the great officers of state who was
sitting around the cabinet table who
know says that he was in some way
deceived no I don't sit around the
cabinet evil I'm not in government I do
attend political cabinet but I knew what
was what was being said and
I'm not quite sure how their former
foreign secretary didn't so it seemed
easy a hypocrite well no you know I
think that what's interesting in today's
coverage is he seems to be spending an
awful lot of time talking about his
London mayoral ship and very little time
in fact he's not even mentioned the fact
he was foreign secretary for two years
and was in the room helping to influence
this and indeed was praising it as as
you know soon ago as as December now
after the referendum in July 2016 you
said in an interview I want to stay in
the single market even if the
consequence of that is maintaining free
movement of labor so is that still what
what was being asked about you know
where my position was in regards to all
of the different options on the table
and I'm a remainer
you know I would have stayed in the EU
if that was the option and that's what I
voted for and if they're aware to be
another referendum not I support one I
would vote for that again but we do have
to respect the democratic mundi of the
the biggest electoral event we've ever
had in this country you know I'm
seventeen and a half million people
voted for something that I didn't vote
for but we do say they have to order
that but you can still honor it by going
further Norway model for example where
we'd be outside of the EU but still
within the single mark
you would prefer that really wouldn't
you well I think the issue that we have
with that is what was it that people
were voting for when they voted to leave
but well I took part in a huge number of
debates up and down the country some of
them televised some of them you know in
ten holes and all the rest of it and was
continually being challenged by those on
the other side by this idea that in some
way and voting leave would get in the
way of trade and one of the main
proponents arguments on the other side
was that we would be able to say free
trade deals with other countries now if
we say in a customs union that's not
something that we're therefore able to
do it also means that any trade deals
that the EU strikes would apply to us
and we wouldn't be able to be part of
deciding what's in them so so you know I
do think one of the issues with the
referendum was that it was a quite a
short campaign
and we didn't explore all of these
options before the vault but I mean I
think I would find it quite hard to
argue that wasn't something that was
laid out by the other site now we've
been talking about brexit in this issue
in this interview and Theresa Mayor
Boris Johnson we've talked about breaks
that yesterday does it worry you that
all the bandwidth if you like in the
Conservative Party is being occupied by
brexit and there isn't enough big
thinking going on on some of the other
issues the domestic issues that are
really important that you're going to
sell on the doorstep I think I think one
of the things that we're trying to do in
this conference is to talk about
practically delivering for people and
that's why you see the announcements
have been brought to have been about
building more homes helping young people
get on the housing larger enough of that
do you think well I think the timing of
this is you know we are four or five
weeks before the EU summit
brexit is always going to dominate and
indeed your questions to me so far have
all been about that because it's the big
issue of the day but don't think that
the UK government is not getting on with
the job because they are and they're
committed to doing so but I do think we
also have to prepare ourselves for a
brexit sort of national narrative what
is the UK in the world and people are
asking these questions and and I would
like to think that I'm gonna be one of
the people that can help contribute to
that debate and to show that we are a
country that childers our burden in the
world that you know we're one of the
people that make sure that the global
rules apply and that we help others
through our soft power we've just
returned for the first time in a number
of years to being the the highest and
most influential soft power country in
the world and and that's why I think you
see the government looking at things
like the festival of Britain and all of
these other areas and now you've written
a book called yes you can I'm quite keen
to talk to you about as well and it's
all about celebrating women's
achievement do you usually a bit both so
it's it's to design to come out 100
years after the first women got the
board and it talks about how far we've
come but actually quite a crucial part
of it is how we've still got our next
steps yeah on that note do you think
Teresa may I mean in ways she symbolizes
like there's a TV shows how far we've
come but do you think she also shows how
far we've got to go I mean do you think
that she
I had a hard time as Prime Minister
because she's a woman
well I she's one of the women that's in
the boot allowed me to interview her and
she talks herself about the work that
she's done in setting up and women to
win which is a conservative accordance
to get more women into politics it's a
it's a nonpartisan book so there's also
their head of the tea you see in the
co-founder of the women's equality party
and and other political women that
non-political women in there as well so
do you think has had a harder time I
think anyone that would be dealing with
an issue as big and as complex as brexit
which had divided the country and and
binary referendums always do would be
under severe criticism at the moment and
would be shouldering quite a heavy
burden in an office and I think we
probably would even know until after it
you know the dust is settled and we're a
long way past that we'll look back and
see just how impressive and how
resilient that she's been during this
time and I think some of the color and
some of the cartoons and the commentary
do absolutely pick up on her feminine
sea and the fact that she's a woman and
it's not harder than the David Cameron
got with some of the cartoons about him
or Tony Blair I'm not so sure and now
it's a very personal book isn't it you
talk about your own experience that's
where the depression yeah actually I
found it quite difficult to read and
that might you know you talked about you
know trying to punish yourselves
punching walls cutting your stomach
how difficult was that political life
also why did you decide to write about
it yeah well it's an I mean it happened
quite a long time ago so it's first
diagnosed with clinical depression it at
18 when I was at university and um I
think looking back on that period no so
that's over 20 years ago you know we
didn't really talk about it very much
there and I didn't have much information
I didn't have anyone in the public eye I
really thought that it was a food
stopped all of my dreams and ambitions
that everyone every 18 year olds has and
I remember speaking to three years ago
to one of the really big mental health
charities and spoke with about wanting
to be able to talk about that so that
hopefully it helps someone else who's in
a police know that I was back then to
know that it's not a full stop to your
life and it's not as if something's
talks about something that happens and
then there's fixed that it's something
that you have ongoing management with
and and it would have really helped me
you know if I had somebody in the public
eye seeing that and we've got you know
Prince Harry and we've got sports stars
and got business people seeing it and
I've not heard that many people from
politics seeing it and it's taking me
this amount of time to kind of work up
the courage and to find a vehicle where
I could tell it in my own words and not
have it distorted through the lens of
journalists like yourself not having an
unexamined life meet something that's
been preying on my mind for some time
and I think if I ever got to the point
and I hope I've got a number of years in
me as a Scottish Conservative leader and
if I ever got to the point where I left
office and I've never spoken about I
think I think I would feel as if I had
done something wrong or done a
disservice or maybe maybe just not being
brave enough or not not done enough you
in in the book as well you talk about
that famous New Statesman article where
they talked about
with children and while it's a few women
with children had reached the top of
context a new right that you're still in
the gray area being and saying that you
have no idea how changing family
responsibilities will affect the way I
do my job inside I'm a do deep are you
worried about that do you think that
having a child might impact your career
to be honest I'm four weeks to go until
my due to eat so I think rather than
worrying about how the child will affect
the job I'm worried about how the job
will affect the child cuz cuz you know
in terms of priorities at the moment
making sure this one comes into the
world and in a you know with ten fingers
ten toes it's kind of the top of the
list but you know it's that party line
you ruled out running for the top job as
well them well no I mean I've been
seeing that for about thirty four years
since David Cameron very kindly tipped
me as a potential successor and it's
been hanging around my neck ever since
there and I know what my job is and it's
in Scotland I don't know what I want to
do and I want to be the first
conservative First Minister of Scotland
and and I want to do that you know in my
hometown of Edinburgh and where I've got
I'm not just the the job that I want and
I'm ambitious for the country but I've
also got all of the other things that
the matter in life you know my loved
ones my family my friends my child
hopefully around me and but but I'm sort
of long enough in the tooth to know that
there are some things that I will be
able to control until I know what it's
like so we've got plan you know we've
got a plan for you know me taking a bit
of time off and then go back to work and
all the rest of it but but we've built
in a lot of flexibility because like
thousands of women across Britain I just
don't know how it's gonna quite work and
before you go I need to ask you as
somebody who played such a leading robot
role in the debates during the
referendum do sports guys campaign to
see an independent commission well in in
Scotland you know we have multiple
debates for every election I've fought
six elections and two referenda in seven
years so we have them all of the time so
I'm certainly I'm well up for any sort
of fight but in terms of having to
create a Crangle to decide something
that's gonna happen two three and a half
years from now I think in terms of the
pressing questions under the UK it's a
little bit further down the list but you
you're
debates it's what I do I do them quite
often and I've never shied away from a
fight in my life okay
with don't force anything very much now
our next guest was at the heart of the
brexit negotiations until this summer
when he dramatically quit over the Prime
Minister's checkles proposals so what
does former British Secretary David
Davis make the situation we're in at the
minute well let's find out shall we
thank you very much for being with us on
it on there early on the Sunday morning
it's appreciated now this is presumably
the last Conservative Party conference
before we leave the European Union Boris
Johnson the former Foreign Secretary on
the front pages of the newspaper today
describing the current proposal on the
table as deranged what's the adjective
that you would choose to describe the
Chequers plan just wrong I mean who
Boris specialized in more dramatic
language than me but it's just wrong I
mean it doesn't do what either what the
referendum led people to expect bring
back control of laws it absolutely
explicitly doesn't do that it doesn't
bring back control of borders so those
two things straightaway it's much more
than that but just two things straight
away doesn't mean referendum promise or
indeed and manifesto promises so it's
not it's not something even when it's
even what he's done
including if we got checkers the Europe
wish you wouldn't go away the toothache
we've had it for 30 years on this
subject would still be there for another
20 years so it's not the right answer
so you know you can't help the thing
thing we're here aren't we in a
situation six months before we leave the
European Union Theresa May says that the
only credible proposal on the table is
checkers you say that it's wrong you can
take some responsibility for a veneer
because she would practice it secretary
for two years we should read my
resignation letter I told her at each
stage where I thought we were going the
wrong way from the way we started
negotiations immediately after the
election campaign the concession on
Ireland in December I said no that's not
the way Prime Minister the end today is
the lead negotiator she decides at each
stage I thought well maybe I could make
that work even though I don't get it
right that lead but eventually got the
point you can't make it work it today it
is so far of what is the right strategy
they listen to you because you've got to
take responsibility for that occasion
because fail to because I fail to
persuade the Prime Minister that that's
quite right and the the simple truth of
it is you've got a whole system here I
mean if you added up all the permanent
secretaries who were voted to leave the
European Union I suspect you've come to
the answer zero you know the whole of
Whitehall has a particular perspective
and I think as I've said already they
miss they misread Europe and misread the
way negotiations should be played they
also misread what wasn't what was an
acceptable outcome for their British
people now all of those things you know
one man couldn't stop one of the reasons
for resigning was to make it absolutely
plain that this issue was not capable of
being resolved at the way the government
was go I couldn't do that and government
I was in government in cabinet took the
view I'm not gonna brief I'm not gonna
spin I'm not gonna talk against my
colleagues you can only do that outside
the cabinet that's
so who is to blame them if it Theresa
May is it is that the officials around
her it's a Tony Robbins it's a mixture
of all don't pick out individual use I
mean I know people love to pick on an
individual but actually it's the whole
system
you know it's stacked in a certain way
and by the system do you mean the civil
service also this the the advisory group
all the all of these people and the and
that the simple truth is that actually
there is a resolution and by the way you
say said he's six months actually that's
plenty of time bluntly I've always said
the prime minister from the beginning
the issue in this is going to be the
last month it's not going to be the two
years that run up to it
it's only the last month because the
European Union always uses time always
try to pressurize you always takes you
to what they call the cliff edge and
then sees if you crank so you think that
will be a deal then yeah I think they
would be me I think this 89 should like
either be a deal and I think actually
the deal will end up as something like
what Boris called super Canada what
somebody else called free-trade plus
basically a free trade base deal but
we're going to have a very scary few
months between now and about November
it's gonna be really scary everybody's
gonna be calling each other's bluff it's
all good all sorts of brinksmanship
gonna go on that's normal that's better
European Union you knows daily bread you
know and that's what we've got to be
ready for that's why what making the
argument now that's why it was important
to resign in energy life because we've
got to make the arguments in in the last
round
checkers won't fly what's Ryan Europe
and it won't fly
in Parliament so Brussels won't accept
challenge I don't agree with Boris
Johnson madam well no I think you see
what Brooke what Brussels may well do it
had some had a few more things on well
yeah a lot of people don't like checkers
even more I think it's the absolute last
step you can go he made all the
concessions again so Russell's are one
of put something else in order for
customs union on a lot of books you know
some other requirements money or
immigration whatever and she hasn't got
any room for that I'm afraid so I think
checkers will die one way or another
either in Brussels or in Westminster and
then we'll need another alternative and
that's why I wrote a basic out wrote
that alternative last lunch dear over a
year ago well let's talk about the
alternatives that are on offer because
there's a bit of an inconvenient truth
isn't there with your alternative some
of them and that is the Irish border
situation it's very serious and what
happens with that border that's awesome
I don't accept the phrase an
inconvenient truth like it's an
inconvenient exaggeration and the reason
is I mean I'm unreasonably familiar with
the Irish border over the course of 20
years or so the it there is already a
border there there's a customs border
there's a there's a judicial board as a
currency border those borders all
operate invisibly you know you could
anyway you can tell is the color of the
stripe in the middle of the road changes
colors available but the customs
operation by talking to each other Irish
and and Northern Ireland customers
manage to catch lots of smog losers who
were the massive cigarette Horomia a few
weeks ago it can be done you talk about
things such as you know Currency Board
of example I mean it's the difference
isn't that between taking some euros
over the border in your pocket and back
and taking some sheep over the border
for example I mean it's a different kind
of border that we're talking about here
isn't it and it's not helpful really is
it to try and synthesize over
simplifying it the Irish government and
the Commission by saying oh you've got
to have a sweeping political answer
there is no acceptable sweeping
political answer what do they have to do
is look at the detail the detail of tax
on the border because it's taxed the
biggest thing you're right it doesn't
matter where you carry a URL or pound
you can buy you can buy your drinks in
in Belfast the euros and you can buy
them in Dublin in pounds the the the
simple truth is it's a tax which we deal
with already its regulations which is
the hardest one and it's what the core
rules of origin that is goods coming
from the rest of the world going into
Europe by bio codes back door through
Belfast we can controller only five
ports in a normal Ireland five big ports
we can control that bit of it the issue
is regulation and you're right it's it's
cattle going backwards across the border
its milk going backwards and boards
across the border it's that sort of
thing and it's important isn't I mean
you and military man you know how
important how sensitive this is I mean
we're still yeah yeah I know something
new some of them but they but the I
raised this in negotiation before the
Commission did for that exactly that
reason I think was a moral
responsibility there so it's not an
exaggeration is it who know what I'm
saying is the problem is being
exaggerated not the important side
I must distinguish that and the
regulatory stuff well there are already
special arrangements along which apply
it's a single epidemiologic result so
you know when you take cattle into
Northern Ireland you don't have to
inspect them you know so you can protect
that if there are special regulatory
arrangements the other thing that's
that's unify between the North and South
is what's called a single electricity
market so you have special arrangements
an ordinal and electricity generators so
you know without putting that border in
the area so you can do minor did not
minor but the significant detail changes
and they're not even looking at that so
would you exceed of the Irish government
before mr. Ferrara came into power and
they were talking about these things and
all the sudden all stopped now it's
being used for political reasons it's a
very important issue but there was being
exaggerated is the difficulty of
resident Rizzoli we can do it and look I
tell you that the best test rather
disappeared the details your your your
your viewers should just ask themselves
who do they believe in is David Trimble
on Northern Ireland the Nobel Prize
winner who put his life on the line to
create the Irish peace process or
Garnier or your Trimble is supports the
arguments I put about resolving our
corporation so would you would you
accept an along the transition to get
this right the water surface we don't
need one I mean you literally don't need
one the you know we've got 21 months
coming anyway that's X that's way beyond
what we need to do this most of these
issues are you know manageable not
because not live there delays the issues
not time the issue is
willingness to take on me take on the
problem and now another big question of
course and as we going to the conference
is leadership
Theresa Mays had a rocky few months
there's been in open discussions about
her future
among
please would you support her leading to
conservatives into the next election
well that's up to her
frankly I mean from the beginning to
keep the red I mean look the the when I
resigned I took a great deal of trouble
to D personalize this because it seems
to me were conflating leadership on the
one hand and policy on the other I want
a change of policy not to change of
leader and where I differ from Baris
whose front page of the papers this
morning is he's conflating the two I
think you know this is such an important
issue we must keep it away from internal
Tory party battles and from leadership
issues such an important issue lots of
things he says I agree with but you know
on this we did let's talk about force
Johnson shall we I mean do you think he
would make a good leader that'll
probably be after I've gone oh you what
clothes do you take you take what he
said this morning and in the papers
there was a council hs2 and spending on
a bridge Norden army well I would I want
to do that I wouldn't and I think one of
one of the blights of British politics
because politicians having fantastic
ideas that cost a fortune and don't do
much good then that will be one of them
if you're gonna you're gonna use the
money use it for broadband or something
else on housing you know he's right the
issue is there but it's answer is wrong
you know that we need to completely
rewrite the housing policy and so on so
you know I know
Boris is great made mine you know we we
were very not about friendship but you
know quite a lot of his ideas I think
are good headlines not their surgical
policy so not perhaps the right person
to say I don't think it's an issue for
today I mean the the real problem is if
we conflate this issue with the
[Music]
they leave the map the mode of brexit
issue we can get motor breaks it rock
because it gets conflated with other
things bricks it matters more than any
leadership issue or leech of interest of
any person that's the thing the public
should bear in mind Bret's it matters
more than a person I wonder if that
applies to Jeremy Corbyn as well and
would you be prepared to vote down the
prime ministers we know that you want to
vote against it if it could mean which
it could mean a general election and
Jeremy Corbyn in number two I don't
think it's not something you'd want to
dismiss the premise really and I will
vote against checkers full stop and it
won't lead to general election
I'm not going to debate the fine tactics
because you're going to Majan it's quite
important how we do that but this is you
know we're capable of managing this
through and and the bigger in what what
used to be the threat was not probably
what used to be the threat
or was a sort of world trade
organization or no deal leave that was
the threat I know that inside out I've
been studying that for two and a half
years there are 300 plans to deal with
it I know it's not to frighten you at
all the project fear things say so I'll
take that risk but we weren't at the
risk report so no no general election
you don't know general election but
there will be a very very exciting
autumn in investment what do you think
happened what because there could
because the government if it's not if it
sticks with check checkers it will
loosen those but and that could be a
problem for the finance people losing
votes is always a problem for a
government but you know governments have
lost in the past
I mean I'm lead the first defeat of Tony
Blair on 90 days he didn't suddenly
resign the next day and that was a
fundamental central policy discovered
okay well we'll have to wait to see
David Davis thank you very much for your
time typing well that's it for this week
but before we go we mentioned a couple
of times throughout the show but Sky
News is campaigning for an independent
commission to organize leaders debates
during general election so if you think
it's a good idea you can search for the
make debates happen petition online and
sign up it's almost at ten thousand
signatures now which would then force
the government to respond now thanks
watching the program from Conservative
Party conference next week we'll be at
the SNP conference in Glasgow until then
thanks for watching
[Music]
you